[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi à 17
novembre les enfants mise à l'honneur à
guyancourt ateliers jeux et réflexions
au programme pour 500 élèves de la
commune dans le cadre d'une matinée
spéciale dédiée aux droits de l'enfant
bertrand ou lyon est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission le maire de
magny les hameaux et nouveau vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
nous évoquerons avec lui notamment le
probable nouveau départ politique que
semble avoir pris l'agglomération dans
le reste de l'actualité retour sur la
comparution au tribunal de versailles le
neuf salariés de l'usiné psa de poissy
accusé de séquestration ou encore la
campagne lancée par l'île de france pour
lutter contre le harcèlement sexuel dans
les relations adolescente le 20 novembre
prochain lundi
donc on célèbrera la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant à
guyancourt 500 élèves de cm2 et de 6e se
sont retrouvés ce vendredi au pavillon
waldeck rousseau pour une journée
d'ateliers le thème de cette édition le
droit à l'éducation et aux loisirs
ils ont ainsi pu découvrir des jeux
vidéos originaux faire des parcours
sportifs ou encore échanger autour de
questions environnementales écoutez à ce
propos le maire de la ville
cette journée ça permet aussi aux
enfants de découvrir qu'ils ont des
droits
alors bien sûr ils ont des devoirs on
leur dit souvent mais ils sont aussi des
droits et droit qui peuvent demander qui
peuvent réclamer
ça leur montre aussi que partout dans le
monde les les jeunes sont pas
effectivement traités de la même manière
et c'est aussi un moyen pour nous de les
conduire vers le chemin de la
citoyenneté une hausse de 0,2 point au
troisième trimestre 2010 est les
chiffres du chômage sont tombés hier
selon l'insee 2,7 millions de personnes
recherchent un emploi en france et à
coignières justement une journée de
recrutement était organisée ce jeudi
plus de 40 entreprises étaient présentes
pour l'occasion technique techniciens
agents d'autres d'entretien excusez moi
ou encore ingénieur tous les profils
étaient recherchés
reportage de camille lambert armé de son
cv et de son plus beau sourire fiona
tente sa chance avec cette entreprise
basée à maurepas
cela fait plusieurs mois qu'elle cherche
du travail dans les services à la
personne
moi c'est plus dans le ménage repassage
les personnes alors je m'oriente vers
plus sur ces stands là pour trouver plus
facilement les cv lettre de motivation
il me recontacter aussi s'il ya une
place énormément besoin de salariés
ça fait un an que que j'existe je me
suis j'ai créé ma société donc l'an
dernier en 2016
je suis aujourd'hui à 10 salariés et je
suis en perpétuelle recrutement pour ni
plus moins répondre aux besoins de mes
clients qui sont des clients réguliers
sur le club intervient chaque semaine
pour effectuer des prestations de ménage
de garde d'enfants et de manière
ponctuelle du jardinage du bricolage
une quarantaine d'entreprises ont
répondu à l'appel lancé par la ville de
coignières pour participer à cette 15e
journée de recrutement
un rendez vous incontournable pour tous
les secteurs de la pâtisserie au digital
ont fait une par an à peu près ce sont
des développeurs web
ingénieur sécurité l'éditeur de projets
les ingénieurs charte comment sur les
métiers de la haute technologie on a
beaucoup de besoins au niveau de nos
clients en gros total et cetera autres
et on a du mal à trouver effectivement
les candidats c'est un forum de
recrutement qui permet à de nombreuses
personnes bien sûr du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines mais également
des communes et des départements
limitrophes même parce que nous avons
des personnes d'eure-et-loir de
l'essonne et qui viennent effectivement
dans ce salon échange de cv prise de
contact qui aboutisse très souvent un
entretien cette année encore environ 900
candidats ont fait le déplacement
est ce la fin des tensions politiques
entre majorité et opposition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines réunis en
conseil communautaire jeudi soir les
élus ont voté en faveur de
l'élargissement de l'exécutif à gauche
ainsi quatre vice présidences reviennent
justement au maire de gauche de
l'agglomération du malandain est élu par
exemple 11e vice président en charge de
l'habitat une ouverture souhaitée
notamment par le nouveau président jean
michel fourgous et qui doit permettre
d'engager la collectivité dans des
projets structurants ont l'écoutent vu
les enjeux aussi bien économiques que
sportives que culturelles
elle a la chance qu'il a d'être de
travail sur des projets comme comme
l'université du futur
la voiture du futur la sécurité du futur
enfin on a on a beaucoup de choses ici
et ça mérite vraiment ce soir ils ont
montré que que ça existe bien l'intérêt
général quand même surtout quand on
travaille on accepte de faire partie du
conseil d'administration qui pilote ce
grand projet d'une belle plateforme
d'innovation modèle en france quelques
doit être saint quentin là c'est plutôt
rassurant
et pour évoquer à cette actualité nous
accueillons sur ce plateau le nouveau
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines et maire ps aussi de magny les
hameaux bertron ou lyon ou bonsoir
bonsoir vous venez d'entendre ce qu'a
dit jean michel fourgous lui aussi
nouveau président de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis quelques semaines
seulement il a aussi rajouté quelques
secondes plus tard vous ne l'avez pas
entendu que vous étiez désormais
réconcilié
est ce que c'est vrai on peut dire
qu'après trois ans de tensions vous être
réconciliées droite et gauche où c'est
aller un peu vite que de que de dire ça
c'est surtout un retour vers la
normalité puisque une intercommunalité
c'est une coopérative de communes nous
sommes sur un même territoire nous
partageons donc les mêmes enjeux de
territoire et je les ai toujours dit
je n'ai toujours répété aujourd'hui on
va peut-être enfin pouvoir recommencer à
travailler ensemble
c'est à dire les douze communes avec 12
légitimité de projets communaux d'élus
du territoire au service en premier lieu
des habitants c'est toujours ce que j'ai
souhaité et cette ouverture vient de se
faire on va voir maintenant au fur et à
mesure quelles vont être les
implications dans tout ça chez logis
aussi en tant que présidente saint
quentin en yvelines avait aussi tenté
cette ouverture vous aviez refusé à
l'époque pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
acceptez les élus de gauche la main
tendue par jean michel aulas il y avait
eu une une implication de l'ensemble des
collectivités au début du mandat de
michel laugier 2014
en 2014 ce qui était une normalité qui a
disparu de son sourire à un moment donné
ça a été son choix de mener une
intercommunalité qui n'était finalement
pas une coopérative entre les communes
aujourd'hui on voit ce que j'espère
surtout c'est qu'on va avoir un
fonctionnement qui permettent le respect
de toutes les communes qui ne fasse pas
penser à une intercommunalité comme une
supra commune qui ferait les choses à la
place justement des habitants et des
élus municipaux donc vous restait malgré
tout attentif particulièrement attentif
à ce qui va se passer notamment les
intentions du président chacun sa
liberté de parole de toute façon encore
une fois il y a un jeu politique qui
fait qu'il ya une majorité et une
minorité mais il y a avant tout douze
communes qui ont toute leur légitimité
on a une diversité énorme au niveau de
saint quentin en yvelines qui a un vrai
atout moi je suis prêt et les quatre
nouveaux nouvelle et nouveau président
vice président
ont toujours demandé de pouvoir se
retrousser les manches avec tout le
monde et pouvoir travailler avec tout le
monde
est-ce qu'il ya aussi les enjeux les
nouveaux enjeux qu'il n'y avait
peut-être pas en 2014 maintenant on sait
que que paris va avoir les jeux
olympiques 2000 24 universités
l'université paris saclay prend de plus
en plus corps il ya le grand paris
express aussi les enjeux sur sur la
ligne 18 est ce que c'est ça aussi qui
vous pousse peut-être à cette fois ci à
ne pas dire non que comparé à il ya il y
a trois ans de passer à côté
encore une fois il n'a jamais été dit
non il a surtout été refusée un travail
en commun à 12 jusqu'à maintenant
aujourd'hui à cette ouverture qui se
fait nous on y participe pleinement
voilà on a dit oui tout de suite on a
planté discussions entre vous on a cru
entendre parfois aussi que même au sein
de la gauche il y en avait certains qui
n'étaient pas d'accord pour dire où là
on a eu une demande on a une demande en
semble qu'il y ait une charte de
fonctionnement
cette charte de fonctionnement
l'engagement a été pris doit être voté
au prochain conseil d'agglomération
c'est important pour pouvoir fixer les
règles de fonctionnement des douze
communes et justement fixé l'enjeu du
respect de l'ensemble des deux communes
la confiance se gagne
donc il faut qu'elles puissent commencer
par cette charte de fonctionnement
et puis au fur et à mesure on va
finalement à apprendre à travailler
ensemble puisque ça fait un petit moment
qu'on ne travaille plus forcément
ensemble mi-octobre je voudrais vous
faire réagir vous êtes un maire on va
dire moderne vous êtes sur les réseaux
sociaux sur twitter sur instagram
mi-octobre vous aviez twitté un article
ou une photo d'un article où il y avait
inscrit en titre quitter son
intercommunalité une séparation
difficile alors je vous vois sourire
forcément est ce que vous vous avez
pensé à quitter l'intercommunalité de 50
ans est ce que déjà c'est possible d'un
point de vue administratif
est ce que vous allez penser
concrètement si vous avez rêvé à lire
j'ai pas réussi à dire là vous donnerai
le lien vers ce magazine très
intéressants qui donnent l'ensemble des
éléments
juridique dgo un gros coup de pression
comme montanier sait simplement que en
tant qu'élu on reçoit un segment de
magazines on lit tout ça je suis tombé
la butte du magazine qu'on reçoit
je suis tombé là dessus je pensais que
c'était d'actualité alors vous êtes
désormais on le précise 13e vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement durable et de la rue
réalité vous avez d'ailleurs un synthé
enfin ce qu'on appelle un synthé qui va
s'afficher en valent les crocs ou pour
bien comprendre votre titre quels sont
vos grandes priorités pour pour ceux
pour la ruralité et le développement
durable j'imagine qu'on pourrait en
parler pendant des minutes et des
minutes mais rapidement si vous aviez un
ou deux dossiers que vous souhaitez
porter vous c'est lesquels d'abord il ya
un projet de territoire qui est en cours
de discussion c'est ce projet de
territoire qui doit être partagée par
tout le monde et qui doit donner les
grands enjeux pour l'avenir de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est essentiel qu'on puisse se mettre
d'accord et partager cet élément ça va
être les points communs malgré tout nos
différentes diversité les quelques
divergences ne sera pas toujours
d'accord c'est pas grave l'objectif
c'est de se mettre d'accord au moins sur
un socle commun et ensuite on avancera
après en terme de développement durable
et de ruralité forcément dans le monde
actuel on pense tout de suite à une
autonomie énergétique
on pense tout de suite à
une diminution des consommations
d'énergie on pense tout de suite à une
autonomie alimentaire
on pense tout de suite au respect de
l'environnement à dans des secteurs
comme comme saint quentin en yvelines à
une un nom et allemands aussi de
l'urbanisation pour regarder des terres
de production agricole qui puisse
revenir directement pourquoi pas dans la
restauration scolaire voilà les la
mobilité c'est un enjeu essentiel à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de se poser la
question tout simplement est ce que il
ne faut pas réussir à faire que les gens
ont moins besoin de se déplacer aussi
par exemple pour aller au travail de
pouvoir penser au télétravail par
exemple par exemple il ya énormément
d'éléments énormément de sujets
développement durable de toute façon
c'est transversal
je travaillerai avec l'ensemble des vice
présidents dans dans leurs différents
secteurs l'objectif est vraiment qu'on
puisse faire de saint quentin en
yvelines un lieu innovant mais surtout
exemplaires on sait que le développement
économique et la priorité est le moteur
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ça depuis des décennies encore
plus envie dire depuis que jean michel
fourgous en est le président on sait que
le développement économique qu'il y
tient énormément et ce qu on peut miser
à tout prix sur le développement
économique et conserver cet aspect rural
est aussi durable aujourd'hui ce que
vous avez pas un peu la vice-présidence
piège jamais diront en tout cas la plus
compliquée le salut est vraiment
ruralité développement économique
développement économique induit
construction de bâtiments de route
d'infrastructures le développement
durable inclut le développement
économique le développement durable
c'est le développement de l'économie au
service de l'humain ça ne sert à rien de
créer des grands bâtiments de
d'entreprise si derrière dans ces
entreprises les salariés ne sont pas
directement sur le territoire si ça
n'apporte pas au territoire et si ça ne
permet pas l'épanouissement humain donc
à partir de là on a aussi tous ces
enjeux de retrouver des formations qui
soit en adéquation avec la population
qui est présente sur sur saint quentin
en yvelines donc des formations qu'on
est aussi de l'emploi qui soit en
adéquation avec ses formations et qu'on
puisse rapprocher au maximum l'habitat
de l'emploi
ça fait partie des enjeux pour éviter
des déplacements trop nombreux alors on
parle de déplacement de transport il ya
évidemment un sujet plus important que
les autres aujourd'hui sur le territoire
c'est la ligne 18 du grand paris express
elle doit relier à l'horizon
initialement 2030 orly à versailles
depuis quelques temps des informations
laissent laisse penser que le
gouvernement pourrait reculer sur le
projet voire carrément l'annuler dans sa
partie yvelinoise depuis les élus du
territoire se mobilisent et une nouvelle
association vient d'être créée tout
juste hier union des élus pour la ligne
on y retrouve notamment le président de
saint quentin en yvelines le maire de
montigny le bretonneux le maire de
guyancourt mais pas vous alors que vous
êtes directement concernés par cette
ligne 18 qui doit passer bien un viaduc
sur votre territoire pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas au sein de cette association
eh bien vous voyez le développement
durable c'est de répondre aux besoins
des habitants tout en préservant son
environnement et en permettant
l'épanouissement des habitants de
manière générale aujourd'hui on sait
qu'on a un besoin d'offres structurante
de transport dans cette agglomération
mais ça fait 40 ans qu'on a ce besoin là
cette offre de transports de l'ue 18 est
intéressante et j'ai toujours dit qu'il
fallait l'astuce est oui j'ai toujours
dit qu'il fallait cette offre
structurantes
maintenant c'est un investissement pour
cent ans on ne peut pas se permettre de
faire n'importe quoi on traverse des
paysages on passe à côté des riverains
de zones rurales là on précise que vous
évoquez vous le casier le réduisent bien
entendu et tant qu'on aura cette
solution en viaduc qui va s'inscrire
pour cent ans dans l'environnement
auprès des populations rurales et là ça
rejoint finalement directement la
délégation que kim ait octroyé au niveau
de 50 ans ni vim il est hors de question
d'avoir un équipement structurant
d'avenir qui polluent directement les
riverains nos paysages et finalement
l'ensemble de notre environ pouvait
encore faire bouger les choses selon
vous on sait que l'algérie ça fait des
années de tout cas ce que ça fasse
reculer le projet dans le temps aussi
que c'est aussi un point sur lequel les
élus locaux insistent ils veulent la
ligne 18 en 2024 sais si c'est parce
qu'il fera reculer
ça c'est des choses aussi qu'on essaye
de faire croire que ça coûtera trop cher
encore hier j'avais une réunion avec
avec la société du grand paris à
laquelle on a appris que le long du
viaduc
il y aura une route pour pouvoir
entretenir le viaduc par exemple ça ça
jamais été présenté dans les plans ce
qui est raconté par la société du grand
paris
aujourd'hui n'est pas forcément toujours
la réalité voilà ça c'est ce que je
crois très fortement
en tant qu'élus locaux il faut qu'on
puisse voir l'avenir à long terme de
notre territoire
et si on doit déplacer d'une année parce
que un tunnelier points un peu plus de
temps qu'un viaduc
c'est une année qui permettra aux
générations futures de vivre
correctement dans cet environnement et
j'imagine que en tant qu'élu local
responsable vous anticipé le pire
imaginons que vos attentes ne sont pas
ne sont pas satisfaites est ce que vous
préférez callamand que le gouvernement
annule la partie yvelinoise de la ligne
18 ou alors il vaut mieux avoir la ligne
18 même en viaduc
c'est le choix du gouvernement c'est
c'est un choix d'état
maintenant je fais confiance en la
sagesse de l'état pour travailler sur un
projet structurant qui soit compatible
avec l'avenir d'un territoire juste un
exemple un viaduc sur cet espace
agricole va tuer les terres agricoles
qui sont juste en dessous c'est c'est
juste un exemple les cds terre de
production qui doivent revenir
directement aux habitants voilà ça c'est
un des éléments par rapport à l'avenir
de nos territoires
bertrand au lion rester avec nous on
passe tout de suite à l'actualité de la
semaine
et cette semaine a été marquée par le
procès jeudi au tribunal de grande
instance de versailles de neuf salariés
de l'usiné psa de poissy quasiment tous
membres de la cgt de la cgt ils sont
accusés de séquestration par l'un des
chefs de l'équipe de lusine un
rassemblement en soutien ses salariés
était organisée justement jeudi devant
le tribunal
reportage sur des images de marie à
pannetrat et des yvelines de
valenciennes et même des salariés de
renault 300 personnes étaient présentes
à versailles en soutien aux neuf
salariés de l'usiné psa poissy accusé
par leur direction de séquestration pour
des faits remontant au mois de février
des accusations que les syndicats cgt en
tête rejette en bloc
pour eux ce combat judiciaire est une
simple tentative d'intimidation
vous savez c'est nouveau pour nous
d'être traités comme des délinquants
comme des voyous de se faire assigner en
correctionnelle alors qu'on n'a rien
fait c'est nouveau maintenant ça ça nous
fait pas peur ça nous impressionne pas
on va pas se démoraliser pour ça au
contraire ça nous renforce
ça veut dire qu'on est des gêneurs on
est des gêneurs dans la politique de
tavares de vouloir exploiter encore plus
les travailleurs le jour même d'une
mobilisation nationale contre la
politique du gouvernement de nombreuses
personnalités politiques de gauche ont
aussi participé au rassemblement
malheureusement cette criminalisation
accrue de l'activité syndicale va de
pair on le voit bien avec l' attaque
contre les droits sociaux et des droits
syndicaux qui sont contenus dans les
ordonnances macro nous sommes toujours
rassemblés quand il s'agit effectivement
de
battre contre des attaques
qu'elle vienne du gouvernement où qu
elles viennent du patronat au moment de
l'enregistrement de ce reportage nous ne
connaissons pas les réquisitions du
procureur de la république
selon la loi les salariés encourt
jusqu'à cinq ans de prison ferme
et contrairement à jeudi nous pouvons
maintenant vous indiquer que le
procureur de la république a requis 5
mois de prison avec sursis pour les neuf
salariés le jugement sera rendu le 20
décembre prochain
bertrand ou je ne sais pas si vous
connaissiez c'est cette actualité à
versailles qui concerne des membres de
la cgt de psa poissy vous avez vu dans
le reportage aimait beaucoup d'élus de
gauche notamment des socialistes qui
étaient présents devant le tribunal de
versailles et qui ont tous dit que
c'était un reflet finalement de la
politique d' emmanuel macron qui
essayait d'étouffer toute forme de
contestation
et est-ce que vous en tant qu élue
socialiste vous avez ce cette même vous
partagez cet avis là sur la politique d'
emmanuel macron j'ai un très profond
respect de la liberté syndicale
et on constate un peu partout un vrai
recul des discussions possibles surtout
dans des grandes entreprises
et quand on compare ça à ce qu'on
découvre au fur et à mesure des années
et ce qu'on a appelé dernièrement les
paradise paper
il ya un vrai paradoxe entre les deux
positionnements du gouvernement
aujourd'hui et d'emmanuel macron en
particulier sur des éléments de liberté
syndicale et des problématiques de
dialogue entre des salariés et le
patronat
il y a directement des réactions quelle
qu'elle soit que je trouve parfois
démesurées celle ci je la trouve
démesurée et à côté sur les paradise
paper rien même pas pas grand-chose à
rien c'est différent ça me gêne
ça me gêne énormément et ça montre que
nous avons aujourd'hui des dirigeants en
france qui ont choisi un camp qui n'est
pas forcément le meilleur pour l'avenir
de la population
merci bertrand au lion d'être venu en
plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de magny les hameaux et du coup le
nouveau vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines en charge de la ruralité et
du développement durable merci et bon
week end verser le reste de l'actualité
marquée jeudi par la mise en place de la
police de proximité de sécurité du
quotidien promise par emmanuel macron
les premières les expérimentations
doivent débuter l'an prochain jeudi à
versailles le préfet des yvelines serge
morvan a lancé une large concertation
sur le sujet en présence d'élus et des
autorités locales notamment objectif
recueillir les différents avis les
besoins et mettre en avant les retours
d'expérience sur le terrain via des
réunions de proximité qui se dérouleront
pendant un mois propos recueillis par
nicolas landry la police de sécurité du
quotidien mais évidemment il faut
qu'elle le soit déconcentré aussi il
faut que son action soit la plus proche
possible du quotidien et le quotidien
c'est pas le même suivant où vous
habitez y compris dans les yvelines
suivant votre travail suivant votre
votre comment pourrais dire votre
situation familiale ce que vous avez des
enfants que vous amener à l'école ou pas
vraiment il ya tout ce qui fait la vie
évidemment du quotidien doit donner lieu
à une en matière de sécurité une réponse
adaptée
c'était il ya tout juste un an dans une
polémique débuté à voisins le bretonneux
autour de la réouverture du centre de
placement de la production protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
les riverains craignent est alors la
présence de ces jeunes ayant commis des
délits
dans le passé nous avons poussé les
portes du site pour savoir pour
rencontrer les résidents et les
éducateurs et faire un premier bilan
dans ce centre reportage de nicolas
d'andré une nouvelle fois bientôt midi
david et youssef met la table
ces deux mineurs sorti de détention ont
été placés sur décision du juge dans
l'unité hébergement diversifié renforcé
de voisins-le-bretonneux on remontait
dans ma chambre je chante ici
je sais c'est pas rangé leurs qui
m'arrange et la france comme on dit ça
c'est la taille projet justement youssef
lui à 15 ans de nationalité marocaine il
vient de sortir de détention
il est arrivé le 7 novembre dernier dans
l'établissement de papel on recherche
travail ces deux jeunes préparent leur
repas un atelier cuisine menée par un
éducateur et une cuisinière au menu
poisson pané et salades crudités
trouvait la cuisson et on retourne
d'accord cet établissement spécialisé
dans la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse accueille des jeunes de 13 à 21
ans
plusieurs modalités de prise en charge
l'hébergement résidence éducative des
résidant en appartement partagé ou des
jeunes en famille d'accueil
accueillant journée sur le site objectif
l'accompagnement à la réinsertion
sociale et professionnelle
cet établissement la correspond plus aux
nouvelles orientations de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse qui souhaite
que nous arrivions à différents si dieu
pardon diversifier les modalités de
prise en charge afin de pouvoir proposer
des
d accueil qui se rapproche le plus des
besoins des besoins des jeunes
actuellement dix jeunes sont placés dans
l'unité d'hébergement quatre ans
résidence éducative dont david et
youssef à terme une vingtaine de
résidants devraient occuper cette unité
de rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
ce week-end avec notamment la suite et
la fin du festival du film documentaire
saint quentin de nombreuses
manifestations sont prévues jusqu'à
dimanche dans plusieurs cinémas de
l'agglomération toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur le site internet du
festival et notamment la soirée de
clôture prévue dimanche au ciné cette
d'élan qu une soirée exceptionnelle avec
le compositeur pierre barou et la remise
des différents prix c'est à partir de
16h dimanche donc au ciné cette
d'elancourt pour les plus sportifs le
vélodrome nationale accueille ce week
end les championnats de france de judo
840 judokas sont attendus sur deux jours
teddy riner d'ailleurs pourrait être
d'ailleurs de la partie
plus d'informations sur le site de la
fédération française de judo
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information en direct lundi à 18h
sur l'antenne de tva 78 en attendant
restez connectés et informés via notre
application tv 78 et notre site internet
bon ok n'a tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]